Con bà trong viên đã quyết, cắn về đức phật về được chả về ấn độ, so hơn một thế kiế lưu lạc tại anh.
Bộ sư tập này được khai khách 5-8 trăm trăm chỉ mệt tắm, tại một bảo tháp cộ ở vùng PIP ROHA,
bằng UTA RODES, cù với cho cót và sương được cho là cụ đức phật.
Bằng đầu, số bảo vận sự kiến sẽ được đưa ra đúng giá tại nhà SOTV,
với giá ước thính hơn 12-20 vệ chính trở đô lầm ý.
Chí phụ an độ đáp phần đối, vui thông bảo pháp lý và kêu gọi khi đúng giá.
Nhật sự tham gia của tập toàn God Rest in the Chí Scrup,
bố sư tập đất mô lại và bằng sau vính viễn cho ấn độ.
Thủ tướng Narandora Modi Gọi, nên là ngày hơn 1 của văn hát dân tộc.
Con bộ văn hó ấn độ, xem đây là hình bẫu hợp tác công tư trong sướng mạnh phục hồi gì sản pháp sáo trên pàn cầu.